what's up everybody vaynerx me friends  vaynermedia and gallery media group  inside of vaynerx and many other things  in my world we are hiring hiring hiring  here's a link to a blog post in my world  especially especially focused on  tick-tock content creation and tick tock  strategists if you are an individual  that's producing tic tocs and it's  working but you want to  instead of just building a personal  brand want to get into the marketing  world revealed please uh please please  check us out but social media creatives  people that actually know how to make a  twitter or an instagram or a tick tock  or youtube short actually work  have ideas  or are a maker of those things either as  the human to be in the content or an  animator or a designer  really excited just a whole lot of  action going on in our world please uh  consider joining the vienna world have a  great